okay
as part of our efforts to get ready for
version 12.3 we are reviewing all sorts
of functionality
and this morning we're looking at the
compiler
so let's get started here
compiling multiple functions
[Music]
it's useful to look at the function page
function compile as well
with this okay all right fine well let's
look at it is it
is it updated it's got it's describing
the new functionality
it's not marked as i haven't added the
12.3
markers but it's have a look at it and
see if it's useful
right perhaps the usage lines could be
simplified a bit
people have been suggesting that yes
that's
which means what i mean well just look
at them for a second and then you'll
see i mean yeah okay
generates a compiled code function okay
from the orphan language function
okay let's talk about functions okay
fine
actually one one other thing is maybe
you should say well from language
function with the
uppercase f as in as in the function
function
because if you give it a function like
bot
then it's not gonna work maybe or a
function like f
i i what i had assumed there was f why
don't you instead of calling it
f why don't you call it funk or
something
um why don't you also be very long for
the subsequent usage
okay okay okay okay all right
um i mean when you say well from
language function it makes it sound a
bit like a built-in function no right
right right right from a from
uh and go ahead and edit this if
okay well i'm thinking of um
from a function from
we wanted to function f i was thinking a
function
well but it might be typed it might have
things it might have a function
declaration wrapper around
it or different exactly yes yeah there
are some other
but we can't say a capital function f
that's totally confusing and not well
yeah
well then why not just
how about how about from a wolfram
language pure function
that kind of gives it gives a
fine okay
but why should it say couldn't just say
a pure function instead of a wall from
language pure function
yeah right why not yes i agree with you
i think it said wolf language at the
beginning that's
i represented that yeah
okay anyway so there's more to edit
there but let's not worry about it i can
i can yeah right okay so now generates
an association of compiled code
functions
okay why is it called l1
label or name or
a1 k1 will be the most natural thing for
key
using auxiliary definitions
what is the auxiliary definition wrapper
there's a thing called
um function
um declaration so
defs is a list it's a list of
declarations and right now i think the
only documented one is function
declaration but they're also going to be
others
well if it's a list then at least show
it as def one def two or something
or can there be a single well the
command can be a single there can be a
single one as well
but okay we don't want to have replicate
everything
no product so i i would just say look
towards these three at the end i would
just say
def's comma funds and make the
yeah yeah let's let's just or f spec
or something yep f spec is good
yeah and then get rid of these fine
sounds
generates compiled code
functions right generates compiled code
or just compiled code well
users
uses the auxiliary definitions defs
yeah one other question is uh i don't
know what other
other doc pages do for this but should
compiled
you know compiled code function is the
head of the thing it generates
so should that be you know space
and so on or
generates a list of it it varies a bit
yeah we vary we talk about list
lowercase or association lowercase
okay fine i i believe right
all right okay so let's take a look at
how this works
compiling multiple functions all right
so
this just does its thing and these
functions can have oh they can't have
interdependency because nothing is named
yet
right actually i believe they can
because you can use
if you read about function declaration
later you can name them
right right i see okay all right okay so
let's look at that
add a function declaration
oh i see the function declaration has a
name yeah and so in this example the
function declaration is in the
auxiliary defs as it's called in the doc
page
but you can also give a function
declaration as the actual kind of main
functions and that lets you name them as
well as like give options and things
why would you oh here i'm totally
confused
this def's function declaration
is based on a named functions
association here is that correct
this references the the case of i
is that correct i don't think so
no well then what does it do what what
what is this steven notice the first
you have a you have the second argument
is a list of function declarations and
the third argument is the function that
gets compiled
so the add two never gets compiled
never gets exposed in the file in the
compiled code
you compile the last function but you
can use add two
before this doesn't document it so no no
to be clear he's talking about three
arguments more function declaration
to be clear these labels are just those
are labels that are not seen within the
compiler those are just for the
the functions that you're going to
return but within the what this function
declaration is doing is it's defining a
function within the compiler called add2
right so that's different from labeling
a function like a compiled code function
that you're returning at the top level
i'm sorry i i'm i'm okay there are two
different ways a function can have a
name
right if the function is just a pure
function that's that's only being used
within the compiler
then you need to give it a name to refer
to it within compiled code and that's
what that add two
is the other case is you have a function
that you're going to return to the top
level
right like in this f spec here and then
there's this label that you can give it
which isn't really a function name it's
just a label
and to keep track of it like in an
association
but could those be the same in fact i
mean could you give a function no no
because the function declaration name
that follows you know that's going to be
a symbol or a compound thing
yeah and that that can be you you know
that that there can be many versions
you know for different types and numbers
of arguments and things like that
the other label is just in the one
compilation
and it has to be unique you know
okay so hold on so let me try to
understand this
function declaration i don't understand
if i have three functions here
add two add three whatever the
declarations are giving their type
signatures correct
and they're in definition oh
oh i see so so then what this is
it might be easier looking at the
compiler environment actually
well but but i mean i'm trying to
understand this this is basically
a junior version of giving uh
down values this would be
more natural it would just say add to
equals typed blah blah blah
and then the payload of what's going to
be returned
is just something that's defined by that
down value am i correct
that's a weird way to think about it but
i guess so i mean this is why right
thomas right you should probably compile
our environment might be more relevant
because basically what this is
this is like a local function
declaration but compiler and the stuff
about compiler environment is like the
global version which might be
make it more clear what's going on okay
create a compiler environment
now we have a
using this compiler environment which
right now has nothing in it
it's got a default stuff in it yeah
okay compiler environment append
which returns a compiler environment is
that true or does it do a is it an
append to
it's like in a pen too then it really
really really really really should say
that because otherwise it's super
confusing for somebody like me
want to rename it i think so i mean
christopher you and i discussed this at
one point i mean
did we come up with anything different
from this compiler environment depend
too
i think it's got to be append to because
it's it's an operation
yeah i mean is it going to show
can i look at what okay so is this going
to take like forever
and it usually takes like five seconds
okay because i want to see what this
actually returns actually i want to see
what the first thing returns there
before what does this return does it
return a blob it returns a compiler
environment object okay which is a blob
of some kind
[Music]
this is crazy i mean okay
oh wait compile environment depend did
return so it modified it and it also
returned is that right
right just like a pen too is that right
it does append to
a pen to returns the modified thing
correct
i think it might actually return no but
i could be wrong
i can't think it well okay let's see
no it returns the thing
so i think this should be compiler
environment append to
[Music]
sure right just one slight thing
most of the things like a pen two they
take a symbol as the first
but yeah i understand that which is why
i don't like this very much
well but but that symbols are you know
that's because normally symbols are the
only things that are mutable right so
this thing is mutable too well the other
possibility will be a name like modify
compiler environment
what do you think about that sorry
we we discussed well christopher and
andrew we
discussed the whole yeah
i think that modify is is kind of i
think a pen two is better than modified
because modify is too vague i mean
another one
we discussed a while ago i think it was
add but then it sounds like addition
and yeah i mean there haven't really
been any great names for this
i mean a pen too is close is closest
because
append 2 is the thing that modifies
mutable things
so i don't think i think that's i mean i
understand your confusion when you see a
pen and you think oh i have to set comp
equals to compile environment append or
i don't
which is harmless you don't have to do
that
so i think append two is fine i mean
it's two more letters who cares
by the way why don't you i mean we could
just make it do that
but we don't want that because we don't
want to we don't want the compiler
environment to be copied
correct in other words we don't want it
to be we want it to be have a side
effect we don't want to be in
multiple compiler environments
[Music]
yes definitely because so an example for
a reason why
it kind of makes sense for it to be
mutable as painful as that is
is something like uh it can cache stuff
so if you do one compilation with the
compiler environment
it will cache things for if you do
another compilation
right and it needs to be mutable for
that
okay
okay but you see what it's actually
doing here is it's just being given a
function declaration
in this case and it's adding that to the
compiler environment
and it's not returning you know it's not
compiling anything
so when it says functions two seven six
one four that's
the number of functions in the
environment yeah i think so yeah
[Music]
my god i mean does it know
i mean that's super confusing to me
because i'd like to know how many
functions
i fed in there and it isn't 27 000.
you want to see what you had it yes
i want to see what wasn't in the only
thing that is slightly weird do
dollar evaluate dollar compiler
environments
so do you really want to see zero i want
to see
one no no don't worry you haven't done
anything with the compiler environment
you want to see zero no no no the
compiler environment is the default
environment you didn't modify that
you modified it so fine but then what
you should do is
is distinguish it um
what's that sorry go go go on okay you
should say
something like um library functions or
something or initial functions
what built in yeah built-in is okay
what are all those functions oh for
doing
all sorts of things but i mean is our
bessel functions one of those functions
no no
i thought they were i think right now
well i mean i'm just taking that as an
example i mean
and you know is uh yes assuming we
implemented them yes they would be
i mean like sign i mean every
the number the reason that number is
huge is because there's things like
all of llvm and all of the c standard
library
and stuff like that and casting and
conversion functions and things like
that
and every internal function to implement
anything
all right okay well that number while
impressive is utterly confusing
let's demote it somehow let's call it
user functions or something
and then let's say zero for compiler
environment for
the default compiler environment and
then say
um
and types is just whatever you randomly
happen to use i mean
there could be some type that is some
recursive type that you define
i mean that this is again user types and
then yeah
right we why don't we call it base
functions base types
and then user functions user types and
do you want to always see them or see
them when you
open the opener i think you should see
user functions and user types first
yeah fine and then see the other stuff
when you open the opener
and maybe if you open it it should say
total or like total functions total
types are all functions all types
because it's
it's too weird just to have this
constant number there that's just the
number of built-in ones
yeah okay fine yeah user functions and
then total functions is fine
that sort of lies what those other ones
are
it's just like okay
justifies why it took it how many
minutes to get the thing
to clear its throat okay
sandra on livestream is asking about
some uh
cpu type dependent stuff we are about to
get to that we have a good solution here
um i hope at least all right well it's
what you wanted
okay terrific okay so
function compile with that compiler
environment now what's the difference
between the definitions
and the compiler environment if i fed
the the compiler environment in the
def's
argument of function compile what would
happen it wouldn't like it
why not because there's a compiler
environment
option to take the i understand that but
why wouldn't it accept a compiler
environment as a definition
because because it doesn't um but why
doesn't it
i think it should just as a courtesy
yeah i mean i think it could i mean
there's
pretty weird drone error if you gave the
option yeah you're putting the
depths yeah no i think that's bad
there's a there's a there's an option
for this okay
maybe maybe maybe here here's a reason
here's a reason why you wouldn't want to
do it
so there's a difference okay so
when you run function compile with with
some defs
it is almost equivalent to running
compiler environment to pen
to and then running function compile
with that compiler environment
the reason it's not the same is that the
definitions that you give
are actually local so what it does is it
effectively copies the compiler
environment
extends to it and then compiles with it
so if you give a compiler environment as
the first argument
it's like what does it mean to have your
compiler environment as a set of local
definitions
yes
um
actually it might be even worth saying
that in the usage line for function
compile just to include the word local
to make it clear
yes what the difference is uses the
local auxiliary definitions
uses the
it's not really local may not be the
right word it's it's the
temporary it's the just for this
compilation
yeah i mean that might be a note
yes i agree i agree but now
[Music]
okay make sure it's properly errored if
you give
a uh compiler environment object
it can have a special error message fine
okay okay uh so what was the thing you
were showing here
you were i mean this looks okay this
compiler environment thing good
i think the idea was just that the
compiler environment made it more clear
what function declaration is doing
which is why suggested going down well
wait a minute so function declaration
is specifying a function in the compiler
environment
that will be globally usable in the
compiler environment
or temporarily usable if it's in the
depths yes
yes you got it correct okay
but i still would like to say
that fundamentally this is a version of
add to equals blah blah blah blah blah
right function declaration is a kind of
more pretentious version of equals if
i'm not mistaken
so the reason why it's not just that is
because there's also going to be other
types of declarations
right right like type declarations or
maybe
macro declarations or okay all right
okay
library the other thing is if their
death was never used
it will it won't appear in the output
yeah so what i mean well whatever i
guess
you know when you do you know colon
equals it's always there
right one question is
in is it possible for debugging purposes
or otherwise
to just evaluate something in a compiler
environment
so in other words in that compiler
environment with that declaration
add two of you know
i i thought about it's not totally
trivial
so is it not just equivalent to function
compile of
function you know and then an empty list
is its first argument and then
your code is the second
maybe
i mean it does seem like it's pretty
easy to do with just function compile
um but well it's not totally clear what
the name would be
what is what are the sub values of
compiler environment object
look at the reference page
these though i i don't know what these
are i haven't seen them but this is
something where we're going to
want to yeah add a bunch of stuff there
because you
like for example this is where you'd
probably have a ton of stuff for things
like
function discovery and type discovery
and and all these
kind of complicated things yes as well
as something maybe as a sub
value which is an evaluation you know a
debug evaluation of an expression
okay all right let's move on because i
think the most important stuff is
is still to come right which is
okay embedding llvmir
okay okay so then this
if i take this creature and i
say i paste it here
and i say 67. oh
why is it why did it take so long to
start up there
why did it take so long to run run it
again
yeah but what was what was the initial i
mean the initialization is not
the worst thing in the world i've been
speeding this up
so uh but try this
that's a nice timing so is that is that
actually recompiling from ir each time
from lvm ir
no no iteration the ir is there
so sorry i think my things grow is it
screen
nice what oh he's been doing
guns oh okay so i guess the question is
that that
short delay when you first ran it was
that
was that just some mathematica code
being loaded or something like that or
was that the actual
initial compilation from the lvm ir
how long does it take to rehydrate it
it's it's got the
you can see the ir is there so the irs
in the
in the output it's just saving it it's
the rehydration what christopher is
asking is was that some kind of compiler
in its initialization
or was that rehydration i i'm not quite
sure actually
so okay fine all right so we'll find
that out
yeah but just to give a sense here
okay so that's the ir
that's the ir for this machine
for a mac system id mac os x correction
86
correct that's why in an association
that says
okay so then then what you're going to
show me is that if i say target system
arrow go down to the next one yeah right
so
okay so this is creating compiled code
for linux
x86 in addition it it always
makes the platform you're on okay i mean
it's all
always already made and it's pretty low
cost i'm just
curious if you look at those uh llvmirs
how different are they for different
platforms are they totally different or
are they just different in detail
they're very similar but not exactly the
same
they have been fun to do sequence
alignment on them or something
yeah they're pretty similar though these
are different sizes i'm not quite sure
where the different sizes
within the same architecture but there's
there's subtle differences of alignment
and
why isn't it why didn't they have a sort
of universal ir without derailing this
meeting
but it seems strange right
because it because it's tied to the
platform you see like
but like it's making libra look it's
different from windows because
the the the libraries have different
signatures
the the optimizer has been run before
the ir is generated isn't that true
the llvm optimizer has been run yes but
and that optimization will be different
on different platforms i assume
because they're different instruction
timings for different op codes and so on
it should be optimal for the different
platforms correct right but
even though it's the parameterizing
those platforms using llvm rather than
their native op codes
but it's running it for a general
machine of this class
not this particular machine
i understand but i mean when you get to
a particular x86 for example
it might have all kinds of different you
know cash architectures and different
numbers of registers and who knows what
else
what takes care of that stuff
well llvm takes there's a header in the
ir that says what the architecture
you're no i understand the architecture
but i'm saying
you know a chip that came off the
production line yesterday versus today
and you know it might have a different
number of you know fast registers it
might have a different
relative timing of some you know some op
code might be in a different place in
the decoder tree
all kinds of weird stuff what what
optimizes for those things
well llvm will do that llvm has to know
about that
but did you mean when it gets turned
into assembler or something
yes when it gets turned into assembler
this is this ir is not
assembler it's it's ir oh i see so so
your point
your point is it's running an llvm
interpreter on that
on that architecture is that right
generating the um
assembly yes that's cool that's the
rehydration part because it has to
generate the assembly from the lvm ir
that's why i was asking if that's what
was taking time but that's supposed to
be very very is it
or is it running at an adjust in time
right it generates
assembler it's doing both actually
so the just in time is also generating
um
assembler but it's laying it out in
memory a little
and doing something a bit like a linking
phase
but without an actual winker i mean like
the just in time that we've been the ldm
just in time thing that we're using is
like
it's a slightly misleading word because
all it means right is that you're
you're you're compiling it and then
directly putting it in memory
instead of making it right right right
that's a complicated question as well
because it really has
genuine just in time and we could do
things lazily and
you know like like you load a whole
package but it just compiles bits of it
and then it did it lazily as as you
wanted to
maybe that would be vastly faster for
the
yes yes there are issues to do with um
um on threading and such like
so this is but so we're currently
getting the best advantage for threading
because the thing is done statically
is that true yes yes it's yes
okay all right target system all
so oh modern
yes okay
[Music]
um so the only thing that's missing from
our
current platforms is the raspberry pi is
that correct the next arm
and uh that's in look look look at ty
that's you do target system goes to full
for that
right so that's out of curiosity i'm
sorry
sorry no i was just going to ask out of
curiosity
if the if there's a standard designation
for mac os x
arm 64 and whether because i'm just
noticing it doesn't have a hyphen in the
arm 64 case
but i don't know if this is a standard
this is power notation um then put a
hyphen it doesn't have a hyphen well
then put a hyphen because it's got but
wait why our designation i didn't make
this one up this is like
you know talk to eti or something we've
had linux on
64 um that doesn't have a hyphen in it
why isn't linux arm64 in this list
because we don't we don't actually ship
one but we've built it
because raspberry pi is 32 right yes
yeah
i would argue that that should be a
hyphen 64. right and i would i would
someone send message to etai
asking him to explain that and john
thoughts that
there's been a discussion on this i
can't remember all the details
okay all right okay mean i don't know
also
oh yes right this this would be useful
for the function repository and sending
to the cloud
right right
do we know what architecture i mean are
all cloud servers the same architecture
and so on
linux x86 okay
they are currently all the same
architecture but i i don't think
i mean that's an interesting question is
whether we guarantee they'll always be
the same architecture
like aws for example i assume that it's
always linux 64. and same with azure
but i don't know that i think it's
impossible
our cloud is special it's a
it's a requirement of our cloud it's
it's set up for these no i understand
that but i'm looking at the following
things somebody produces a compiled
function they push it into the cloud
they wait a year they come back they run
it again
if they didn't get so actually what are
we going to do for this
i see so so worst case is it recompiles
for some new architecture
worst cases it recompiles from some
architecture yeah
okay and it what does it do with respect
to the user when it does that
does it say recompiling well moment
there is a
this is waiting for some other things
there is a progress monitor system
okay fine so that so that would should
show its request i think that should
show
progress yeah okay so then let me make
another comment if it's an api that's
running in the cloud
and had to recompile clearly the api is
going to be pretty dead in the water
if it has to recompile
do you understand what i'm saying so
right so i think
that should be we should understand that
as a process if the cloud
ever gets machines with a different
architecture it's got to go through all
the apis that are stored there and
recompile them
right
i mean i assume that the yeah things are
stored in mx files in the cloud aren't
there as well
yes so that would also appear
if we ever had 128-bit version in you
know
an x-files a platform independent within
the same
word size i see
well it'll be a while yeah i i
think so i don't know that there's any
pressure for hundreds the compiler might
be
100 might be a thousand times faster by
then
i should certainly hope so yeah okay
okay embed a library all right so this
is terrific
and this will allow you you want it and
you like it you want to look at the
function page for actually look at the
option page
go to the function compile documentation
page and look at the options section
oh well you can see possible settings
for target system are
all full
i would take out all possible just say
for all machine
architectures right right now are you
sure you don't want to have that be
automatic target system arrow automatic
for key machine architectures oh it
could be automatic i think it makes more
sense to have it
i i i agree and and then
the default case where you say
target system
no i mean science system
or target system
look that's crazy because target system
has to be able to include the self
system
right i think target system could be
default to inherited
and then the other settings are
automatic and all
fine so the default is inherited fine
that's what i'm thinking yes
yeah find that and then just say machine
architectures for which
code should be generated and by the way
if you can make these one line it will
be really nice right i'll i'll i'll
work on that okay
uh and this should presumably
link to dollar system id here
it doesn't but it but it certainly could
all target systems and then dollar
system id perhaps
hello
is something frozen
i don't know well you haven't frozen
i've not frozen is anybody else here
i'm here i think we lost steven okay
right now
occasionally my network goes weird so
that's what i'm
uh
um
hello that's utterly bizarre my computer
just switched itself off can you hear me
yeah me no yeah yes
we still see your screen that's really
bizarre with a blinking cursor by the
way
yeah well i wonder how i get to unshare
because
maybe the screen just disappeared let's
see
can i throw myself off uh
you tried moving your mouse just to see
if we can see your mouse move
no i went to a different computer now oh
um
stop sharing oh good okay
all right so let me start sharing again
yeah
okay so i'm afraid i have to oh that
means that i didn't commit
those changes so that has to be done um
could somebody message roger well i'll
message him
um
so are they going to get committed is
that gonna be possible or
yeah um
i guess it depends on how far gone this
computer is
okay all right let's go back to what we
were doing here
uh so let's see so devin had sent me
email with the review page
and i have to launch that in 12.3
why is this not coming up okay there we
go
okay all right
we are down to embedding a library
right so i i've implemented this
in my development system so we we can
have this in 12.3
what does this do what you wanted
this embeds a shared library
in the compiled code function so it can
only do it
for the one platform but it uses the
embedded library if it's there
and that's a little bit faster
okay i think this should say use
embedded library
arrow true because this is too similar
in name to embed code and things like
that
yeah fine fine well hold on hold on
yes maybe but it's possible we might
at the moment we just say true or false
or something but
we might have the right hand side be
libraries but
other platforms that might be useful
somehow if you could make them well you
mean you mean
a bag of diet a bag of bits well
an association of uh system ids and
byte arrays but
maybe use use embed library i
actually i think i like using bed
library use embed did library
i think and they're dead library
i think so isn't that what you're
describing this to be
it's not necessarily saying that you
should use who is it it's saying you
should
create here is a library oh it's saying
you should create one yes
yeah that's why i chose embed library
because it's a verb
but i don't like that because it's too
similar to embed code and that's a
function and it's just
too complicated explain exactly what
this does again
right this does the compilation
and then it creates a
shared library equivalent to the
compilation
and embeds that in the compiled code
function
okay and then it should say use embedded
library
use embedded library fine so what's
different
what's different when you don't use that
option it doesn't and but it doesn't
insert an embedded library and
that affects what it means there's
rehydration that has to be done
it's storing only the llvm ir rather
than
i mean there's a possibility that target
system could have a decoration that
means
make the actual embedded library for it
see
now we're starting to use target system
in three very different
modes so i i i think this should be
quite separate
all right okay well for now it can be
but i i i can imagine a time
when it says you know mac os x blah blah
blah
dash library
as a target system kind of concept and
possibly the target system name isn't
quite right
well right it might not be but it's fine
but look
target environment might be better
that would be a system id or a system id
together with a decoration that says
whether it's
ir or whether it's raw library
i think target system's better than
environment sounds too
all right well fine but i mean but i'm
saying that i think you could decorate
the system names to indicate whether
they are like oh i see i see
i see you've got to actually give the
library somewhere yeah yeah
look for now let's just say use embedded
library yeah i'm i'm i'm happy with that
okay all right so then we're on to this
okay dandy right
there's maybe another topic with types
which is not for right now
but that is the so the reason why
declare types isn't in here
is declare type sorry type declaration
we go with function declaration right
the reason why that's not in here is
because
uh you know you need to be able to
specify a type
and right now we don't have a design for
that right now so that's a future thing
but um what do you mean by specify a
type so
if you want to be able to say oh i want
to declare a new type it's going to be
uh type product right and then you go to
the type test
is that what you mean correct or does
the type declaration right it's not just
a i mean
type def and c just renames things right
but
right i see there needs to be a whole on
the whole language for specifying i mean
not a whole language but i mean there
needs to be
a couple probably like four primitives
for representing different
types and things like type products and
so on so what you mean
yeah yeah yeah i mean type products
probably type aliases
type sounds um yeah
maybe function types maybe um
yeah but i think that needs to be done
holistically not not piecemeal
so yes yes so that that's i'm just
mentioning it because there's a type
section here
correct right this integer one two this
is a hot this is hardware
hardware integers not not software i
understand
so so what is that generated can the c
compiler generate these or not
yes c compilers can modern c compilers
can generate these yeah
do we use them in our i mean do we use
them
i don't know charles pooh has this um
library that he's the number theory
library that might use things like this
okay pretty nice to have in the compiler
so it is nice it's very nice
yeah um
okay by the way various people on a live
stream have been commenting that
aws does have non-linux instances
um okay data structures right and these
are some new data structures that we've
got
immutable vector
okay
mutable vector so let that generate a
new type
new data structure every time the append
operation
it is really is append it's making a new
one it makes a copy
but it's done super efficiently
okay so it's like association but it's
right and this is a
rob a rob thing
i was going to ask why uh i thought
usually with kd trees you you
you keep going until every vertex is
either in its own box or or there are no
vertices in any boxes because they're on
the edges
pictures you could join rob to this
conversation i mean
i think it's fine this is like a detail
but
well
it may he may also just be showing only
the first few layers because i think
they're very noisy
something like that yes i
did this graphic get worked through the
design department
no i think i think it should be so it
needs to be because it doesn't look
right
i mean blue is not a color we're using
for these things
i don't understand why it's so big i
mean a bunch of issues here
yeah fine that's that's totally fine
okay so
and and what and so okay question i mean
what is the list of other data
structures which because it seems like
the compiler
should be getting to the point um
where we can have you know where it's
easy for people to produce data
structures
here's a question if we had a data
structure repository
could people contribute to it i i think
i think that would be possible i think i
think we need to
we we need to do this work to finalize
the type language
because that's that's what they're okay
but something so witnessing let's just
understand that workflow
so the possibility would be that data
structure of
of quotes foo would be something that
was a user contributed thing
in a data repository and that would give
us an and right now our documentation
for a data structure is a well-defined
piece of documentation but it is not
repository
you know you can't add to it in a
repository yeah
that's that's that's that's true so the
relationship between
a data structure repository and the
built-ins
would be the same as the relationship
between function repository and built-in
function
so it would have a slightly different
page right um
i i think that would be interesting it
seems like a useful thing to have
yeah yeah yeah i i i agree with that
i mean and i you know perhaps at least
in time for this year's summer school we
could have something
where people could actually write some
data structures
um so another question i mean so our
built-in data structures like the graph
data structures
where are we at in terms of gatewaying
those over to the
to the system
that i think that needs if i try and
bring that up they'll say they've got to
finish i think that's a great thing to
look at post 12.3
well i mean the main issues i think i
think that a lot of those data
structures are
kind of complicated even stuff like
associations
but like graphs for example i i don't
really know i haven't looked at the
code but i think that like some graphs
are represented
with um you know uh like sparse arrays
for their adjacency matrices and some
graphs are represented with
you know vertices and edge lists and
yeah well right but this is exactly what
they're not written they're not very pop
they're not polymorphic as well this
immutable vector is is polymorphic it
could take
anything take you know instagram 28s and
be super efficient for those well but
wait a second wait a second
what christopher's saying which is what
i believe to be the case is that the
graph wrapper
actually is is you know it's like a tiff
file
there are many possible representations
underneath of the graph
depending on what the structure of the
graph is which is very cool
and very you know the fact that i don't
even know what those representations are
is a good sign
but so my question is so that means that
what data structures could potentially
do is unpack that
and provide graphs in you know one of
five representations or whatever and you
pick
yeah so if you want the automated one
just use graph
and otherwise this is this is picking a
particular one i actually ran into
something like this the other day which
is maybe for sparse arrays because i
know they're like
i don't know like five or six different
standard spurs array representations
and i think our sparse arrays like the
thing with head sparseray just uses a
particular one
but that's interesting you might want
other ones well then that's another
thing so if we could try to generate a
list
of what data structures we might want
that will be very helpful because then
we can try and figure out how to get
that done
and as the compiler gets better that's
one of the things that we can yeah yeah
you know i've got quite a good idea of
what i mean i have a program and
you know like for him works on these but
you know i think we can just steadily
fill this out
like i think some of your you know
extensible bit back to things that we've
talked about
that would be useful okay all right okay
um and more immutable ones in fact
i think we could implement association
it's
it's it's pretty similar to this
immutable vector well that will be
useful
obviously if you're compiling internal
code yeah yeah
yeah i mean being able to compile
associations would be extremely useful
yeah yeah yeah no no we okay we should
discuss what that means it's
it's yeah yeah yeah because there are a
few different there's the tuple case
versus exactly
the dictionary case yeah yeah yeah
but yeah i have some ideas about how we
could abstract over that as well
okay fine i mean the the big heavy
lifting is going to happen after that
yep um okay let me just comment on a few
uh things that came on live stream
muhammad is complaining about something
to do with secured authentication key
i'm afraid this is a profoundly the
wrong group to talk about that
saying that documentation for secured
authentication key is terrible
okay wait a minute secured
authentication three does support
oauth 2.0 i believe
uh using it while using url read it's
just the wrong group of people here
um uh devon if you can take that comment
and give it to the right group of people
that would be helpful
sure i think that's ece yes
that's correct uh
muhammad is asking about type of type
some which are not explicitly coming in
twelve three they will be subsequent
uh
let's see
how distant is wolfman language api for
vm instancing as opposed to cloud api
services from the
cloud computing market
i think you might be talking about uh
well from application server
which is which is just about
to uh emerge right andrew
yeah i mean certainly um
it's certainly beta now which is welcome
if we have a genuine interest
just to explain what it is for people i
suppose on the live stream and perhaps
even people here but
but um so it is
a containerized modern
system containerized containerized and
built for
kubernetes container management system
ability to deploy
uh what we're calling active web element
servers which are
kernel pools that you know serve up
apis and other api like things
so if you have any you know where you
would cloud deploy an api
function you would deploy something not
quite the same way but you would deploy
the wolfram application server behave
they
behave the same way but this is for
people who want to essentially set up
their own clusters
that handle uh cloud uh will from
uh wolfram language apis and things like
that
and but i mean the actual deployment
there is a service to
is it is it yeah it uses service deploy
so it uses a slightly different wolfram
language interface because it's not
cloud but it's pretty it
it's pretty much the same as cloud
deploy you have to specify just a little
bit more
but it's just you have to specify what
the destination application yeah you
have to specify
you have to specify you have to specify
what the resource you know what you're
going to
refer to the resource to internally and
then you have to specify the external
path
those are kind of the extra bits of
information that you don't with cloud
deploy because cloud deploy just
makes a url for you here you get to
control what the url is it's your server
but
you have to specify it but i mean
i mean the point is that small details i
mean in terms of if you can cloud deploy
then you can understand how to deploy to
application server it's nearly as easy
is there a default for service deploy
that generates a uuid url
no i don't think there is right now
would that be useful
no probably not yeah i agree
and okay well it's cool i mean that that
term so i
i think that answers the the what was
raised there
okay well good stuff okay so this
compiler we have a few changes here
we'll get those
uh documentation things that i edited
committed
and then we're off and running and um
yeah sounds good okay can i get that
function compile notebook from your
other computer can someone send that to
me
yes ask ask roger did devon please
communicate with roger get that tab yeah
yeah but he should just commit it
because yeah yeah it's missing it would
be great committed it just has to be
maybe that machine can be logged into
remote there no
i'll just ask him to commit it okay
great
okay thanks guys i'll have to find out
what happened to my other computer
um
might have a second channel
oh general object record data structure
yeah that's someone else we'll answer
that the answer is yes
though um okay good stuff see you guys
later